so tell me what is it like to be part of
such an incredibly huge universe like
this you know it was a great opportunity
look for yourself here's the real
hannibal burris and here's the imposter
so you were invited to the hollywood
premiere of spiderman and i couldn't
make it mm-hmm i still wanted to be a
part of the premier so i
i hired somebody to go for me have a
great time
all right you guys that was hannibal
bravo
come on come come on come on you know a
lot of options here
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
sparkle premieres tonight
i even got a [ __ ] watch on you call
my boy
what's up
hello what's up man it's joe carroll yo
yo yo
yo
what's happening man yeah remember the
the red carpet
yeah i remember yeah good to hear from
you man appreciate what's what's up hey
what's good dude hey check it out man i
just got a uh email you know i heard you
guys got another premiere tonight the
news
yeah yeah yeah what's up dog so uh so
what time do you need me what do i need
to be at
um no no what time do we meet you there
might meet you at your spot is that what
we're doing or what we're gonna do what
we're gonna do this time i came through
for your boy man yeah you did yeah man
you appreciate that so much thank you
dog oh okay that's what's up so i mean
you know we can we can split it uber or
something you know what i'm saying like
uh
no no well i don't need you for this one
because
that was the thing with i got my mom's
debit card man like we can we can we can
run this thing up
with the other one it was i couldn't
make it so i sent you in my place
but this one i'm
i'm i'm going to
because i'm i'm going to it i they're
fun they're like really lively
so what you're saying uh
blessings spider-man and theater
december 17 peace
[Music]
oh
okay
[Music]
hmm you know this could be my villain
origin story
huh
i still live in media